we welcome you back to CBS mornings as
Americans cast their votes on this
election day we're looking at two big
issues the state of our democracy and
election security Now the White House
said yesterday there were no credible
threats to security but U.S law
enforcement has warned about domestic
violent extremists there's also some
concern about candidates refusing to
accept the results we're joined Now by
CBS News Chief election and campaign
correspondent that's Robert Costa Face
the Nation moderator Margaret Brennan
and our chief National Affairs and
Justice correspondent that is the great
Jeff begaze we welcome you all to the
table listen earlier in the show we have
the CBS News Battleground tracker Bob
I'm going to start with you capitalist
economy inflation crime followed by
election issues guns and immigration the
point is the state of the democracy is
not in that list not even in the top ten
what does this say to you about what
voters are thinking or feeling about
that issue because Democrats have hit it
very hard while polls show the economy
and other issues are certainly at the
top of mind for many voters Gail I
really believe based on my travels and
Reporting in recent months that voters
do care about democracy but not in the
way Washington understands it when I'm
on Capitol Hill and people talk about
democracy that word usually is a
shorthand reference to the capital
attack on January 6. but when I've been
out in the south in Pennsylvania in Ohio
in the the Southwest when I talk about
democracy it doesn't just mean talking
about January 6. it means talking about
redistricting voting rights the
Integrity of the broader American System
that's what people are concerned about
this year and can't you care about both
right you know that's right you can it
doesn't have to be one of the other
that's what I'm thinking it doesn't have
to be either or Margaret what about the
effect of this what will the impact have
on this election if people don't accept
the results that is a big concern it's
it's hugely corrosive I mean this system
only works if we continue to have faith
in our institutions and the basic
premise is that we settle our
differences at The Ballot Box and not at
the barrel of a gun but some are already
laying the groundwork though Margaret if
it doesn't go their way we are and
that's why I think we in our jobs too
need to be so clear that it is not a
flaw it is designed in the system this
is going to take time they're not going
to have uh absolutely clear views on
some of these very closely uh fought
States and in some places we might have
run-of-the-mill stuff like recounts and
re-examination of ballots that is
entirely different than completely
sewing uh doubt in a way that makes
people say you know it's not even worth
me voting because if you say I'm staying
home you leave that space to be filled
by the loudest most extreme voices and
we have seen that highlighted that
direct line and I know Jeff knows this
between domestic violent extremists and
those who are denying the results of the
last election yeah that spot on is
linking that well said and speaking of
that system Jeff when it comes to
officials what are they most worried
about when it comes to election security
uh violence you know and it's so odd to
be saying that in this democracy we've
all covered enough elections but this
one is different yeah and it's it's not
a presidential election but it's a
midterm election with the prospect of
potential violence hanging out there and
so you have law enforcement they're on
pins and needles they say they're ready
they're monitoring social media they're
looking out for potential domestic
violent extremists the kind of people
who sort of look for an excuse to to
lash out to cause problems and so
they're paying attention to that but
just the fact that we're talking about
this on an election day in this
democracy Post January 6 you have to
because of what happened that day and
law enforcement does not want to be
caught flat-footed this time around yeah
and what do you say to voters that are
nervous about going to the polls we've
seen pictures of people at polling
places looking very menacing some of
them armed and you can see the arms you
can see the weaponry and they've been
told to stay away in law enforcement
sometimes in plain clothes they're
watching out for that you have doj
monitors being dispatched to election
districts across the country so as I
said they're they're preparing for this
because no one wants any type of
violence which could happen because of
some of these operations these influence
operations coming from China we've seen
them active in this space over the last
couple of days you have Russia any uh
this Putin's Chef okay that's what we
call them because he has catering
contracts with a Kremlin that's his day
job but in his spare time he runs this
internet research agency that that tries
to stir up trouble online here in this
country sowing divisions around issues
like abortion so they're watching out
for that as well and Bob you know
president Trump has been teasing he's
got a big big big big big big
announcement next week do you think that
the outcome of this election these
midterm elections will affect his
decision one way or the other or do you
think he's already decided I'm running
his allies say he's moving towards
running and that's likely what's going
to happen next week he's going to be
watching tonight at Mar-A-Lago I'm told
by his friends and supporters how his
candidates do he endorsed a lot of
candidates this year he wants to claim
at least partial credit should
Republicans make major gains tonight at
the same time his talk of an early
announcement this far ahead of 2024 some
Republicans tell me privately it's not a
sign of strength for Trump to try and be
jumping in this early that if he really
had commanded the party he could take
his time and wait but he knows there are
so many other ambitious Republicans who
are hovering over his own shoulder
Governor Glenn Younkin of Virginia
governor Ron DeSantis of Florida as Tony
has just been reporting on all of these
names are really become a galaxy of
rising stars in The GOP Trump knows that
and that's why he's talking about
getting in and potentially trying to
freeze the field the world is watching
Margaret how are we being perceived by
our allies well and until this will also
impact about the President Biden runs
again in 2024 our allies are watching
that they're watching what's happening
right now and I was speaking to a
Western European Diplomat who said to me
she grew up looking at the United States
as a Bastion of democracy and she was
sad that she doesn't feel she can't
because these divisions are exploited by
our adversaries and and really it hurts
America's ability to project power but I
just want to underscore that Homeland
Security officials easterly was on Face
the Nation recently underscoring
election infrastructure they have
confidence in the Integrity of it so I
don't want our conversation here to turn
people away from going and exercising
their vote today no doubt about it
Margaret Bob Jeff thank you appreciate